right under 37 percent he can keep you
honest out there
cj will once again take valentine's to
the rim and has success
a second time alan tunis had 18 rebounds
last time these two teams met back in
february
damn pitter-patter dribble right hand
from the left side the patented damien
lillard finish
and lillard with it for portland and the
trail blazers with a chance for the lead
and again
lillard on a blow-by things aren't going
well
could always use valencianas cj mccollum
with the finish as we go to rob
merkich with a screen mccullum with the
straightaway three puts it in
and cj mccollum with 13. paint points
out doing the grizzlies of what the
grizzlies do best
dame working against jackson jr that
right hand
facing up into the jump shot good kick
out from cj john morant came to the
paint he collapsed him
so he knows you got to go close out on
my man got to take him off that line
is up 5 37 seconds left cj
working against jackson jr the floater
from cj knocks it down
and cj with 19 in the half
lillard again able to get dribble
penetration sets up gary trent jr for
three
with one tenth of a second this is on an
island i mean that's exposed but he just
fights it through and that that like
motivates day mental
guards getting to the paint nerks
involved in the screen but jaron jackson
jr he's not willing to abandon nerc
even though dame has the step on his
teammate it means that he's matched up
with nurkic and on the offensive end
nurkish does not have the foot quickness
to stay with jaren and jaren has taken
advantage but nercus nice roll
and finish there blazers throw the
grizzlies by nine just over 1 30 left in
the third quarter dame trying to work
against oliver shakes him and dame
rolls in the three so the blazers after
a couple of possessions cut the deficit
to sit
pressing up on him there he is got
got anthony toliver tripping up stops on
a dime
hate to shoot for the blazer cj catches
in the corner goes baseline over brooks
floats one up over the top
smooches the backboard and the blazers
down one
and both lillard and john moran in the
top ten in scoring in the fourth quarter
nurkic back on
white side goes out mccullum hits
i understand why this is a part of the
game but i would love to see
hey that's okay you may enjoy american
dame work the two-man game cj
up top against moran five to shoot cj
gets into the lane tough floater
roll same leg same hand hold the shot
use of nurkic
damn up top nice through a couple of
defenders dame with the left hand
luscious as that rolls in blazers trail
by two
last few blazer baskets dame get into
the middle
launching and figure guy in the middle
cj found zach zach found mellow now cj's
going to keep it himself pull up
tough pull up by cj he buries it blazers
up one with a minute left coming alive
for the blazers
cj able to use the screen now re-screen
just keep going left
keep going left so you get a good
harassing d
by gary trent jr and now lillard
straight line driving the finish too
easy and portland is rolled out
to an eight-point lead in the grizzlies
called the time long way in helping the
blazers in the playoff race
cj against brooks five to shoot cj step
back three
splash mountain baby blazers up 11.
there's a bucket here would go a long
way towards their efforts dame able to
get into the paint rises
up and how about the finish damian
lillard a hot knife through butter
man dame's drive
you can always rely on him to deliver
damien lillard